on dit que vous ne riez jamais est-ce
que c'est parce que pour vous la
politique est un sacrifice que vous
faites à vos convictions ou est-ce que
vous y trouvez quelquefois un plaisir à
l'exercice de la politique non je trouve
un plaisir l'exercice de la politique
quand cela permet d'avoir un pouvoir sur
la réalité des choses sur le cours des
événements par contre la politique qui
consiste à s'engager dans de longues
campagnes électorales et à essayer de
faire du cinéma devant les médias ça ça
me plaît déjà moi alors la politique
c'est aussi un spectacle à partir du
moment où vous entrez en politique vous
vous mettez en scène question indiscrète
pourquoi est-ce que vous pouvez vous
porter une chevelure postiche
cela il faudra d'abord en faire la
démonstration
[Musique]
non j'ai pas de réponse à cette question
qui me paraît pour le moins sur grenus